Democrats last night won two
gubernatorial races in states that voted
overwhelmingly for Hillary Clinton last
year although the mainstream media
reporting would have you believe that
CEO Hillary Clinton Asst just sacked
Carthage and sewed the fields with salt
we will analyze the analysis then Liz
wheeler Alicia Kraus and roaming
millennial will join the panel of
deplorable --zz to discuss the first
publicly transgender state delegate
Danica roam Stephen Hawking suggestion
that robots might kill us all a
bodyguards complaining that Mariah Carey
sexually assaulted him as seriously and
how the California n-double-a-cp wants
to ban the national anthem I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show all right we have got a lot of
election analysis we it's actually not
election analysis that I'm gonna do
everyone's gonna do that I'm gonna do
election analysis analysis so there's
gonna be a meta-analysis we can't get to
that until we're still reeling from the
hundredth anniversary of communism and
of the October Revolution so we have to
acknowledge a little bit of capitalism
great capitalism news Marshall is still
gonna be here he still has a job for the
next few days because we have a sponsor
we have a great sponsor that you should
hear about which is policy genius I
actually have a little personal
experience with this and I really
recommend it if you don't have a life
insurance policy doesn't matter how
young you are especially if you have
kids get life insurance it is not that
expensive especially if you go to policy
genius I understand getting life
insurance it's very complicated
I didn't want to look into it I hate
dealing with paperwork and having sales
reps call me and try to scam me out of
my money policy genius takes all of that
away
it's like turbo tax for life insurance
so you know if you're adult you need it
it's so easy to put off it's confusing
it takes forever you have to speak to an
agent usually just to get a quote I hate
talking to people I do but you hear
maybe once or twice a show talked to
Marshall that is the only time I speak
to him and there is the only time I
speak to anybody here otherwise I add
that's enough at AU sir
otherwise I'm just sitting in the bench
for a broom closet policy genius you
don't have to talk to someone if you
don't want to obviously they have a ton
of representatives available who if you
want to get a little explanation they
will lay it out to you in plain English
but if you just want to browse you can
browse you can lurk you can figure out
your own policy it lets you compare life
insurance from top providers online
takes as little as five minutes let's
say you're a busy man like I am then you
can just do one minute for every five
days or you can do thirty seconds for
every 10 days if you find a policy that
you like and you want to know more you
can talk to one of their licensed
experts but if you're just browsing
don't talk to anyone just browse they
don't just do life insurance you can do
a lot of other stuff their disability
insurance renter's insurance pet
insurance and you can compare health
insurance as well so if you need life
insurance but you've been putting it off
don't put it off seriously who really
affects people's lives the lives of your
family and your friends so if you've
been putting it off try policy genius
you can compare life insurance online on
your own terms in your own time policy
genius.com because you should only be
forced to speak to an agent if you have
committed a federal crime go to policy
genius comm and give them a little love
because they're helping keep the lights
on so go over there alright that's
enough about capitalism now we have to
get to the this major loss for
capitalism because Democrats won last
night
now look I'm probably a little older
than you folks I am old enough to
remember a few months ago when John Asaf
was the great Democrat hope he was
running in Georgia sixth Democrats put
twenty four million dollars into this
race this was going to be the Trump
referendum they couldn't wait that's how
every mainstream news article was
billing up in the weeks leading up to
this and then he lost and then the
Republican won and he lost said this was
the mainstream media coverage the next
day Democrats were so excited about this
twenty four million dollars in here's
our stake here's our anti Trump stake
here were the headlines quote lessons
for Democrats from the Georgia election
okay
did George a congressional candidate
John Asaf really get roasted by his
opponent depends how you cut the video
quote John also have lost but so what
it's all about the long game Democrats
it's nice Republicans avoid big loss by
forcing runoff in Georgia House race
they avoided a big loss you know by
winning that's a you that's how you
avoid a big loss
all of those headlines by the way we're
just the Washington Post they're all
just from one democracy dies in darkness
everybody that that's just the
Washington Post everyone else was
equally downplaying this major loss for
Democrats and then last night Ed
Gillespie a Republican candidate lost in
Virginia he it's a blue state we all
thought he was gonna lose the poll
showed that he was gonna lose guess what
happened he lost these are the headlines
Washington Post antitrump backlash fuels
a Democratic sweep in Virginia and
elections across the country NPR in
backlash to trump Democrat Ralph Northam
wins Virginia governor's race as a
backlash that's how that's how in
anti-trump candidate won a state that
voted for Hillary Clinton that is a blue
state CNN Donald Trump was the big loser
in Virginia MSNBC after election
backlash Trump's GOP is lost without a
map only Newsweek actually surprising
only Newsweek offered a different view
running the headline quote did Trump
will e really win the election so I
thought that's kind of interesting
Newsweek is the only one that's giving a
nuanced no they were talking about the
election last year they weren't sure if
Trump won the election last year they
were so they were so blinded by their
shock and misery that Donald Trump lost
exactly one year ago today that that
that was their headline today now
obviously these guys are really good at
getting talking points they must you
know I I don't think it's only the
Russians who hacked the DNC server
obviously it is going on to every
mainstream outlet in the country that
this is supposed to be evidence of the
great backlash there's no evidence of
that Virginia is a blue state it's been
getting bluer for a long time they've
obviously voted for Hillary Clinton if
you're if you're corrupt and Democratic
and blue enough to vote for Hillary
Clinton probably a lost cause and you
know Gillespie's a fine candidate he's
run before he's lost before I feel bad
for the guy he was a good chairman of
the RNC but you know it's a loss there's
a loss no getting around it as Chris
Donovan from ABC News points out though
Trump is the fifth president in a
to have his party lose both the New
Jersey and Virginia governor houses in
his first year in office five in a row
in both states that's what we saw last
night obviously there was never a chance
the Republican who was gonna win in New
Jersey that was that was a fait accompli
it's also worth noting that in Virginia
the Gillespie's Democrat opponent
Northam had a vote advantage of about
260 thousand votes so a lot of people
have been like you know when you read
about natural evolution door winning and
evolution and all the little swamp
creatures crawling out of the water onto
land that's basically what's been
happening in Washington DC to Northern
Virginia so alas alas too bad for Eadie
amazing to look at the difference in
coverage though because that that was
the big winner last night the big winner
last night wasn't Northam wasn't the
Democrat in New Jersey wasn't even the
State House delegates in Virginia the
big winner was the mainstream media
narrative what a night for them for the
first time and now over a year they've
had their narrative justified for an
evening congratulations good for you
Virginia by the way also elected one of
the first publicly transgender
candidates in the country Democrat
Danica Rowan Danica Rome is a man who
has transitioned to look like a woman
over Republican Bob Marshall very
socially conservative candidate who had
put forward a bathroom bill the bathroom
bill you know there's awful terrible
bigoted laws that say that men should
use the men's room and women should use
the women's room here here is a clip of
that candidate Danica Rome
[Music]
we made history tonight we County and
that's part of a mystery tonight because
we'll now have a trans woman who can
finally fixed route 28 I spent nine
years two months and two weeks as the
lead reporter the Gainesville Times car
my whole community it is about time that
the administration in particular and
other people start trash-talking
reporters and start respecting the craft
because local journalism is community
service it is public service and the
people of the 13th district just
supported to elect and sent a reporter
down to Richmond I'll always be a
reporter before non-politician on the
trans part there yeah I am a transgender
woman we won because I am a transgender
room because I am a reporter because I
am a lifelong medic resident asks
because of my I had inherent identifiers
not to spite them I never ran away from
them I championed them and because of
that yeah from Swain County is no is now
more inclusive than it was there it is
I'm actually really shocked it's really
a sad loss in the culture war obviously
that the voters of Virginia would
consider electing a journalist to any
office really upsetting that's not good
any anybody who's worked in in news like
that is just by definition disqualified
from holding any office in government it
is a little strange obviously that if
for those who can't see the clip there
obviously this person is a man who
dresses like a woman and has long hair
we had Blair white friend of the show
came on a few weeks ago and said gender
dysphoria is clearly a mental illness
it's a psychological affliction
although mental illness is probably a
prerequisite for holding political
office anyway so that doesn't bother me
too much but all of this to say it
doesn't seem to me a shock that a state
that elected a man who looks like a
woman basically on the platform of
looking like a woman would would not
vote for george w bush's Republican
National Committee Chairman Ed Gillespie
this is not you know earth-shattering
stuff here there is also another point
to consider which is the Democrats are
less popular according to a recent poll
than they have been in 21
years then they've been in a quarter of
a century I'm a little torn on this CNN
just did this poll and they found out
the Democrat approval ratings down to
about thirty percent the lowest in a
quarter of a century but if CNN is
reporting it then doesn't it mean that
that is fake news and Democrats are very
popular
I don't know I'm caught in a real
paradox here according to this poll
thirty thirty seven percent of Americans
hold a favorable view of Democrats this
is down from forty five percent in March
a precipitous drop it's down from sixty
two percent the day that Barack Obama
was elected the first time doesn't seem
to me a random chance or a random
coincidence that the high point of
Democratic popularity was the day Barack
Obama was elected it's been sliding down
steadily ever since Republicans are also
unpopular now they're about thirty or
thirty one percent but the thing to
point out here is over that same period
Republicans have never been higher than
forty eight percent approval and yet
they have one massive victories and
elections across the country so I it's
one has to wonder what that says about
public approval ratings according to
these opinion polls for Democrats versus
what they say about Republicans
Republicans have been able to win major
victories during this point Democrats
not so much we'll see if this election
of Virginia and New Jersey has any
anything to say about the upcoming
elections for that we'll have to bring
on our panel for analysis we have for
the first time very lucky to have from
OAM Liz wheeler we have from the
youtubes our favorite or you know she's
been with us since the beginning roaming
millennial and The Daily wires very own
Alicia Kraus ladies thank you for being
here Liz was last night a referendum on
Donald Trump no I don't think so I don't
think by any stretch it was a good thing
for Donald Trump it wasn't a win for him
but it wasn't a win for the American
people either we elected these radical
leftist candidates they're left on
abortion they're left on taxes they're
left on foreign policy they're left on
immigration it's not a win but I think
we make a mistake with all these hot
tapes and anybody on Twitter certainly
saw a bunch of those last night we make
a mistake generalizing the results of
these elections and assuming that they
mean something for what's gonna come
next year they don't necessarily you
talked about that fact that five the
five
last presidents of the united states
have lost both the new jersey governor
ship and the virginia governorship this
is not as unprecedented as democrats
would have you believe and they also
always lose seats they lose seats in
their midterms right they this is just a
matter of course the question is how bad
will it be I guess
roaming who is happier about the loss
last night president Trump's critics on
the left or president Trump's critics on
the right oh I think President Trump's
critics on the left for sure I mean I
think they're both happy but what I've
noticed is that the mainstream media and
you know leftist pundits they're trying
to compare this to the quote shellacking
that Obama received with the whole tea
party elections during the the midterms
and it's just it's just not comparable
this was an off year election and you
know like you said people are toning it
as this like this turn around we're
gonna see like you know the the resist
is coming no this this this isn't I
don't think representative of you know
huge changes and voter attitudes I mean
Trump's only been in office for what is
it ten eleven months now even though it
feels like so so much longer I think we
actually want to get an accurate pulse
of the way the public is you know
receiving the Trump presidency you were
gonna have to wait until next year I
mean this wasn't great for the
Republican Party but I wasn't this huge
loss either I just feel bad for Ed
Gillespie I really like the guy met him
a couple times at events and he's just
this old school Republican he's very
nice he's not intimidating he's not loud
or yelling that's maybe that's why he
lost maybe you should have been a little
I'm not enough edge not enough edge you
need more Kofi Fahey gotta turn that FFA
up to 11 now President Trump speaking of
the father of our country who appears to
be the president for centuries it now he
tweeted out last night he said quote ed
gillespie worked hard but did not
embrace me or what I stand for
don't forget Republicans won four out of
four House seats and with the economy
doing record numbers we will continue to
win even bigger than before
Alicia is trump throwing his own guys
under the bus here what happened oil tea
huh yes he is and if he was so right
then how come his candidate didn't win
in that special election down south I
mean hate to break it to them but just
because he endorses somebody doesn't
mean that they're gonna win or just
because someone hugs close to him
doesn't mean that they're going to
either I think that New York and New
Jersey racists do not surprise me at all
it looks like in Virginia I'm kind of a
geek when it comes to the numbers when
it comes to campaigns and the turnout
and the type of people that turned out
to vote and how often those people vote
and you're seeing that the GOP did not
do a good job I think that they were
counting on people rural Republicans
specifically to get out and vote for
Gillespie and it just did not happen
well in light of that race in Alabama
when it was Trump endorsed the more
establishment guy Luther strange and
Bannon and some of the Trump base were
supporting Roy Moore who stood firm on
the Ten Commandment statue at the
Alabama courthouse and all of that is
this evidence that the you know the
Trump e'er candidate they're one even
though Trump hadn't endorsed him
is there a trumpism without Donald Trump
is there a base movement that he really
ought to get behind that doesn't doesn't
only follow him I don't know that
there's a trumpism without Hillary
Clinton and I think Virginia is a really
good example of this I think that and
I've been saying this for over a year
you have to look at the nitty-gritty of
the numbers you have to look at the
individuality of every candidate every
precinct and every campaign and in
Virginia I'm a fan of Ed Gillespie too I
think one on one he's a great guy but he
really isn't a good charismatic
statewide candidate yes and in addition
to that you had some really tough attack
ads that some horrific attack ads that
we've seen if the Democrats are
apparently apparently going to continue
to double down on and those worked in
the northern areas of Virginia where
it's really all DC Beltway workers that
live across the river and then vote
Democrat I know and I think love Trump's
hate I actually never understood how
they the left uses that slogan as an
anti Trump thing it would seem to me
that's a pro Trump stay where I love
Trump's hate but unfortunately didn't
Trump 8:00 last night with those
ridiculous ads conservatives mowing down
little brown children and trucks not
what we saw in New York City a couple
weeks ago how about this transgender
candidate Liz is there is it a little
strange your gender dysphoria is
obviously a psychological affliction is
it is is mental illness just an
occupational hazard of politics what
should be our takeaway from this elec
well I think the takeaway with this
transgender candidate is first of all I
don't care how someone identifies that
all that you can identify as a multi
gender unicorn cat if you want if you
want to scale back the role of
government in our country then I will
support you but that right there is the
difference between the Republican Party
and the Democratic Party Republicans
want to elect people based off of the
principles and the policies that they
stand for Democrats don't have to vote
for people right exactly Democrats want
us to vote for people on their identity
furthermore this is funny to me actually
that women's groups especially on
Twitter I think Planned Parenthood and
they roll some of the other liberal
feminist groups are actually celebrating
this as a victory for women and they
can't even it's not even a real woman
here this is a man who feels like a
woman who is dressing like a woman and
somehow that is supposed to be a victory
for women how dare you I can't believe
we would allow this and I had train song
in my head which is never a bad thing
roaming what is the what is the takeaway
here in terms of the culture right now
people seem to suggest the left is
suggesting that transgenderism is the
new civil rights frontier you know black
people were excluded from any political
institutions than they were allowed in
and that was a great victory women were
excluded that's a great victory but is
mainstreaming this sort of delusion
mainstreaming illusory feelings about
what one is physically or metaphysically
is that the next civil rights frontier I
mean it this is a hard issue to talk
about because on the one hand I'm very
sympathetic to people who suffer from
gender dysphoria I can't imagine what
that must be like that's you know it's a
terrible terrible mental issue and I
really really think that you know people
who are footed with that they deserve
our compassion because rod Blair white
right and but at the same time I feel
like people especially on the left the
progressive group they're trying to
normalize this you know paint this as
just perhaps even like as you know
something like oh yeah another sexual
orientation no big deal very common and
it's not and what I'm what I'm really
worried about this is how you know the I
think heard is it pronounced wrong I'm
not really even sure you know I don't
have any Romy
Millennials I don't know you know but I
would yeah so you know with her I don't
have an issue with her being transgender
I mean if you know she has good policy
suggestions and you know she's committed
to serving her constituency but when she
doesn't there I mean she made it all
about identity politics she said that
yeah you know I'm a trans woman and a
journalist and I won because of that and
all of that and I think that's really
the wrong message to be sending to
people that you know not only is
transgenders I'm something that we
should be tolerant of and accepting
toward in society but we should actually
be actively voting for people because
they are trans I mean that that doesn't
seem like a healthy stance to take
toward any mental issue not just
transgenders I mean like I won because I
have clinical depression that doesn't
sound right and it's the same thing for
transgenders and I'm not sure why we're
glamorizing it plus whatever you think
about transgenderism obviously we should
never support sending journalists to our
with you because you stole my journalism
Joe to quote a great man said okay we
listen guys I know this this it might be
the most COFA a panel I have had on in
months I know you want to see more we
have a lot more to talk about we have to
talk about Mariah Carey sexually
assaulting people or something and
Stephen Hawking predicting the end of
the world and that racist national
anthem of ours but if you don't
subscribe then you can't see any of it
sorry buster thank you to everyone who
does subscribe we appreciate it helps
keep the lights on keep scoff FA in our
Cup if you don't go to daily wire.com
and and by the way the reason you're
gonna want to subscribe right now is the
conversation is coming up be sure to
tune in to our next episode of the
conversation it's Tuesday November 14th
5 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific and it's
featuring little ol me yours truly the
conversation goodbye that's right it's
hosted by Alicia you you've done a
couple of these they've been pretty fun
right yeah it'll be lots of fun in our
promo that we taped was also lots of fun
we got through like take 37 we finally
were able to get it mainly because of
you I mean I'm always professional I
know I'm I try I pride myself on never
being professional the conversation will
stream live on The Daily wire web site
Facebook page and YouTube channel it
will be free
for everyone we are so charitable but
only subscribers can ask the questions
subscribe today to ask me all of the
most important questions and join the
conversation
daily wire.com you get me at the end
reclaim ensure you get the Ben Shapiro
show forget all that who cares
conversation ask questions no one really
wants the answers I'm just gonna stare
blankly for 90 minutes anyway but you
get the leftist here's tumblr there it
is baby this is a fine vessel I was
hoping it would overflow a little bit
more after the Gillespie race last night
but don't worry there's plenty more to
come and you so you go over there right
now daily wire calm we'll be right back
Stephen Hawking he is / you remember
Stephen Hawking he is predicting quote
AI artificial intelligence could be the
worst event in the history of our
civilization you know some say the world
will end in Wired some say in vice from
all the gadgets I've acquired I hold
with those who favor Wired but if the
droids are fair and nice I think I've
seen enough decay to know that for
debasement Vice is a-ok and will suffice
roaming should we fear our robot
overlords are we just Luddites afraid of
change and progress I mean I think we
should absolutely fear our robot
overlords if you look at any attempts at
a I am via the Google team and they've
they've had a something that in the
works for a while they've actually
released transcripts of the
conversations they've had with these a
with this at AI and it's absolutely
terrifying what it presents is like a
nihilist view and I guess very very
condescending view of humanity and
different AI see also refer to putting
people into people zoos I mean if we're
creating something that's logical
fact-based I don't see why it would have
any reason to not go completely Skynet
on all of us and I mean if you talk to
people like Ian musk he kind of seems to
share the same views so I'm not really
sure why he's at the forefront of it all
but yeah I mean I think it's completely
reasonable to be skeptical of AI and
frankly I'm not sure why so many people
are watching such a big push for it and
it is true when you read those
conversations they're terrifyingly
nihilistic which makes perfect sense
right because it's a you've created a
contraption that has a version of
intelligence but not consciousness not a
soul not a relationship to God so you
know I'd probably have a pretty bleak
view of we sophisticated Apes running
around also I mean it's kind of it's
kind of interesting if you whenever I
talk to atheist they often bring up why
would God create something that he knew
was so awful that that wouldn't obey him
that would kind of just go against his
his desires and I mean aren't we doing
the exact same thing with AI at this
point Plus also freedom is a good per se
you know so what we
as conscious being can have will and a
loving God might give us freedom per se
we're just all making sex robots you
know because that's really what so is it
it's gonna be over anyway once we get
the sex robots so well I guess if
they're gonna shoot us too so bad
Liz why the tech guys are all afraid of
AI as roaming points out Elon Musk and
all the rest of them is it because they
have an exalted view of Technology or a
debased view of humanity I'm not afraid
of artificial intelligence or robots I'm
afraid of the people who are in charge
of them the people who are programming
them I mean taking this Stephen Hawking
thing for example this is the man who
can't who wants to give a citizenship he
wants to make these things people at the
same time he can't even define an unborn
baby as a human being here he's telling
us that we're on the brink of losing the
earth to climate change in global
warming but he comes at that without a
scientific fact these are the people to
fear here not the actual machines the
robots themselves because that's what
they are they're machines they're robots
we don't want them we turn them off
it's evidence to that smart people are
so often just the dumbest people in the
world you know they're very extremely
intelligent but they miss essential
facts about the world Alicia would it be
possible to stop the advancement of
artificial intelligence even even if we
wanted to
not without the Avengers I mean I saw
age of Ultron I don't know about
everybody I don't know I'm definitely
team Elon here and I'm not team Elon on
too much because I don't like Tesla's or
how they took my
taxpayer-funded money to you know stay
in the black but it's just a little bit
ago and and I am team Elon that be
careful of the robot overlords and I
agree with Liz I don't really trust the
robots themselves or the people that
made them and their ability to shut them
down but I mean let's be honest Google
in every and Apple and everybody already
knows what's happening anyway because of
our watches that we wear and our iPhones
that we keep with us that's even robust
they discovered even Roombas are keeping
track of your your housing plans so just
you can't trust anything not even the
beloved Roomba oh that's that's no good
and and when the sex robot
comes the Rumba then then we're really
there have a lot of information I cut
you off Liz no I said that's
heartbreaking and I thought rumbas were
just toys for cats
yeah sacred anymore
I am glad to hear Alecia - that you're
not on Team Elon mostly because that I
don't care how much they try to make
environmentally friendly cars seem cool
they aren't cool the only cool hybrid is
a Lamborghini that burns gasoline and
motor oil nothing else is cool stop
pretending
okay let's move on to sexual harassment
finally we a little sex so there's all
this stuff about Kevin Spacey he
sexually harassed some eighteen year old
in Nantucket or Fire Island or who knows
like places that are made for sexual
harassment crazy summer parties and all
of this but those are the serious
allegations here's it here's a much more
important one Mariah Carey's former
bodyguard is accusing her of sexual
harassment according to page six Carey
quote beckoned him to her hotel room
where she was dressed in sheer lingerie
and then she performed sexual acts with
the intent that they be viewed by The
Bodyguard I I'm almost getting choked up
reading this harrowing account of this
awful assault and harassment belen 2017
America people though never believed
male victims why do we treat male sexual
harassment differently than female
sexual harassment well I think it's part
of our societal instinct to regard men
as always being the predators as always
being the aggressors you know the ones
who are out there looking for sex and
then I you know ask gentle women folk or
just the you know the delicate flowers
who can either choose to accept or
reject the advances I think it's very
modern of Mariah to you know try and
bridge that gap in the sexual harassment
cases you know it's very very
progressive but I think this is kind of
representative of the larger problem
we're seeing hi I would've just abuse of
power you know people who are in these
positions where they're you know there
is someone's boss they're in charge of
them financially whatever kind of
breaking that trust that exists between
a boss and employers subordinate and
their superior and I mean if it's true
that this happened this is this is
really too bad it's unfortunate and
hope it wasn't too scarring for the
bodyguard because I'm not I'm not sure
when exactly this was alleged to happen
but Mariah now and see-through lingerie
I don't know fair enough
I guess you know I guess I'll take the
radical position here that I don't think
it is possible for a big strong
bodyguard to be sexually harassed by
Mariah Carey I know this is radical in
2017 but there is this double standard
you know and that image not harassing to
the eyes yeah well it could be I haven't
seen Mariah in a while you're I'm
thinking of like 2002 2003 but you're
right I mean to 2017 that could be a lot
Alicia there's this double standard you
know the teacher the cute blonde teacher
has sex with a 15 or 16 year old male
student and all of the guys say oh where
are those teachers when I was in school
uh but it should there be a double
standard or male and female views of
sexuality different male and female
views and instincts and just the way
that we were sorry made by God are
definitely different I think we're
triggered by different things or turned
on by different things we're trying to
turn off by different things and I think
that the study of this the New York
Times actually believe it or not an
interesting piece about this that unlike
other crimes sexual predators or men
that are accused of rape is very
different and cannot be broken down by
race ethnicity financial background
upbringing etc but they're the two
things that are typically known is that
when they come to power they feel more
empowered to do things and get away with
it and when they're surrounded by other
people that are guilty of the same thing
and I think that what that's what we've
seen in this Hollywood culture that it
wasn't just Harvey Weinstein it was
other people around him and if they look
at Harvey and said oh well he can get
away with that why can't I then that
kind of creates a really bad snowball
effect of one guy doing it and then
another guy doing it and thinking that
they can get away with it and that's
what creates more victims and more
predators and Mariah Carey I've never
thought of lumping Mariah Carey Kevin
Spacey and Harvey Weinstein into any
bucket you know together but I mean can
we claim harassment for her New York you
know New York Times Square's
certainly triggered possibly harassed
all right well poor Mariah poor
bodyguard you know I hope I hope he
recovers from the trauma
our hearts go out to him the California
n-double-a-cp
the California n-double-a-cp is now
claiming that the national anthem is
racist
according to CA n-double-a-cp XYZ LMNOP
president Alyce Huffman quote this song
is wrong it shouldn't have been there we
didn't have it until 1931 so it won't
kill us if it goes away or I won't kill
us if it stays there too right by that
by that logic Huffman also claims that
Colin Kaepernick's NFL take a knee
protest that the message was distorted
and it became about the flag initially
wasn't about the flag and it was
distorted beyond recognition to become
about the flag so now in order to find
something to quote bring us back
together
she is protesting the flag she's
protesting the star-spangled banner the
line in question that they're talking
about is from the third stanza that
nobody has ever actually sung but good
fair enough stanza no refuge could save
the hireling and slave from the terror
of flight or the gloom of the grave now
Alicia you know that Americans don't
study history ever anymore before we get
to what that means did this
n-double-a-cp state president just
completely validate trump's
characterization of taken a right he
said it was about the flag everyone said
it's not about the flag and then she
comes back and says it's about the flag
is the Kaepernick protest a protest of
the American flag and therefore the
country that symbolizes oh absolutely
and I think it always has been and I
think that Kaepernick and lots of people
that would jump to defend him we're
trying to be like oh no no it's not an
insult to the military it's about Trump
or no no it's not about the flag it's
about Trump but it just goes to show
like you said they don't study American
history and they don't understand the
basics or the fundamentals of the flag
or what it stands for and that it
doesn't matter who's in the White House
the eight years of Obama I didn't like
that guy either but I still you know
pledged allegiance to the flag and
saying the national anthem at every
public event or ballgame I went to
that's true roaming you're a well-known
multi-ethnic racist is the national
anthem racist no I don't think so and
you know it's kind of great because
Trump will come out and he'll say these
like ridiculous things like you know
first just looking federate monuments
there wasn't gonna be the White House
next
as crazy as those are they prove him
right it's the you know the most uncanny
thing and I think with this it's really
it really just is hysteria I mean if you
look at how the anthem is sung right now
there's absolutely nothing racist in it
I mean a stanza that's not included that
most like 99% of people I would rate
wager don't know about verses you know
to what the what the anthem has come to
mean to so many people across the
country I think it is just ridiculous
that there that they would even think
that this would be a good idea I mean
like you can say that a we didn't have
it before 1930 like what's what's the
big deal I mean we didn't have women's
suffrage you know we didn't have like
just because it hasn't existed for the
entirety of the nation's history that
doesn't mean that it's not important to
it anymore I'm not sure what even
argument they're trying to make with
that of course in the poem by the way
the defense of Fort McHenry was written
in 1814 about the war of 1812 and this
point you know on this point of the the
third stanza people don't know what it
means and I don't mean that like I know
what it means nobody knows what it means
because Francis Scott Key who wrote it
never told anyone what it means what we
do know is that the British policy of
impressment was a major issue in the war
of 1812 so the what Brits were doing was
capturing sailors and then forcing them
to fight for them so plenty of credible
historians think that that's what the
slaves they were referring to if they
are referring to American slaves they're
not referring to any old regular
American slave they're referring to
American slaves who fought for the
British the reason I'm impressed by the
impressment argument is that the first
word is hirelings right so they're
referring to the typical British
practice of using mercenary troops
Hessians in the in the Revolutionary War
hiring out troops from Germany and and
elsewhere so of course no one certainly
not this woman Alice Huffman but very
few people who take issue with that
stanza have any idea about any of the
history of the song the poem of war of
1812 the British Army none of it right
because why read a history book when you
can just tweet out a hot take Liz where
does it end
does it end as Romig suggests with
taking down statues of
Washington you know if we're going to
ban every person place and thing that
falls short of the glory of God then
we're not we're only going to be left
with Jesus and look what they did to
Jesus the only guy will be lovely Jesus
look at they didn't treat him very well
I don't know I don't think that we are
that the glory of God is not under
attack to just look at what happened
after the Sutherland Springs shooting
liberals all over Twitter even our
elected representatives were attacking
prayer they were attacking Christians
who said that we were going to pray for
these people the only thing that our
nation can do after a tragedy like this
yeah this is not this is not about
patriotism I'm gonna go back to the
point that you made about distinguishing
what what Colin Kaepernick's original
take a knee protest was about if you ask
any one of those players not one in ten
would actually know what they're
protesting because it morphs it morphs
from Colin Kaepernick's original
protests of police brutality which we
know is a false narrative to being about
the flag because America is inherently
racists and white supremacists and the
patriarchy and then it works again
introduce hatred of Trump they're gonna
latch on to anything they can to take
Trump down because that's what they want
to do and if they have to instill anti
Americanism to do it they're gonna
create it wherever they can
you know we've we talked a lot yesterday
on the hundredth anniversary of the
Russian Revolution of the October
Revolution about useful idiots and we
see them galore here useful idiots and
idiots in part not because they're
unintelligent but because they're
absolutely ignorant and uncurious about
the things that they're shrieking and
hysterical over ladies I wish I could
keep you on the panel all day and for
all the rest of the panel's because
instead I'm gonna have to talk to Jacob
berry or somebody thank you for being
here we have for the first time
Oh Anne's liz wheeler we have from the
youtubes rummy millennial Daily wires
Alicia
Kraus all right everybody that is our
entire show today get all of your
mailbag questions in I will change your
lives tomorrow so make sure that you
send them all in and that by the way go
and subscribe to another kingdom we have
over 500 I think reviews at this point
we I got one negative review I have one
negative review so far on my performance
of Andrew clavin's news story another
Kingdom and it was pretty brutal I'm
almost positive that it was
written by my third cousin once-removed
Hillary Clinton that's all I can
conclude from it but please go over
there it's Andrew Flavin's another
Kingdom you can get it on iTunes
stitcher pod Bay I don't know all those
places that you kids download podcasts
and please subscribe and leave a review
really helps us out and then as
Hollywood lays in ruins of buildings and
studios and bathrobes we will as
conservatives be able to build it up
with a decent art and literature and
culture again so please do that tune in
tomorrow
I'm Michael Knowles as the Michael Nolt
show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
marshal Benson executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey
supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
austin stevens edited by alex is and
Garo audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Jeshua alvera and
our associate producer is Bailey Lynn
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
for word publishing production copyright
for word publishing 2017